[Music]
[Applause]
marcus spears uh nfl analyst for the
mothership contributor to get up nfl
live sportscenter and many other
programs there you can watch him at four
eastern every weekday with laura
rutledge ryan clark minikimes and dan
arlovsky including today free agency
officially begins marcus let me start
there what would you do if you're the
cleveland browns
try to get to sean watson dp yeah um
i think that you know it's funny the
relationship is severed already uh dan
and dan actually dan olofsky talked
about that
the day after the season when stefanski
and baker had
um how could i work conflicting
uh
definitions of of how the season went
um
but
even with all of the things that i don't
i don't ever talk about deshaun watson
without talking about off the field
because he could you could trade for him
and he still have to sit out
12 games or a year so you make you you
are bargaining and betting
on if you cleveland with this going
public
you are bargaining
that
we may not get deshawn and we may not
have baker
unless we force him to be here right
because i believe that it could get very
ugly and the fact that baker uh you know
made that statement on social media last
night
it lets you know where his head and his
heart is
and
a thank you like i'm departing is not
the same as a thank you like i'll see
y'all next year but do you think he
knows something because it felt
premature that he would put this out and
he's not a surrender guy he's going to
fight through it
and
you know man when you
first of all all of these guys and i
know we we kind of inflated with baker
all of these quarterbacks got egos man
and
regardless of what people like to
believe
i played in this league nine years most
of the most of their egos are fragile
when it comes to the business of
football and how
their perspective organization looks at
them so the fact that you're in a you
you are your name if you cleveland and
your name is a part
of the rush and the the war to try to
get desean watson
um you got a quarterback that you
drafted in the first round that was
planning on playing
on his fifth year option for 18 million
dollars and now he knows you don't you
would prefer someone else so
i i just
he knows but i don't think deshaun
watson
in full totality
led to the ultimate dece i think baker
has seen some of the writing on the wall
for a while now
because you remember dp we had a we had
a conversation this season
um
about his backup his name slipping me
right now but if if he could actually
start and do a better job
or the guy that came over from minnesota
yeah case kingdom so
even with that type of discussion
you know that that's not something that
the media made up or somebody on the
outside that's a legitimate thought
that they were having about do we have a
better shot and i know the injuries
played a part in that but ultimately man
it's been tumultuous for baker for for a
while and his play hasn't kind of
overcome that but he made the mistake
and i said it at the time it was a
mistake i understand the mentality being
a competitor he played through pain
and he didn't play well
sit down man
sit down and i think it cost him i think
that cost him ultimately that we looked
and went
is he a franchise quarterback do we want
to give him all that money
because prior to that he played well now
is he a is he a first-team you know
all-pro quarterback no he's never going
to be that
but i describe it like this dp i think
baker mayfield is an average quarterback
that plays above average at times
and i don't know
if you're cle see cleveland well based
off of that though marcus you got to
trade him you got to move on if if you
think he's average and occasionally can
be better than average then you move on
but dp that's what his listen you know
how this go that's what your resume says
if you're baker mayfield your resume
says that you have played
elevated football at times but the big
sample size that we have including the
injury because to your point he should
have sat down
right but you you try to play through
that you go back to turning the football
over he had the one year when they made
the playoffs where he had i think 26
touchdowns and eight interceptions or
something like that that's solid but dp
ain't nobody going nobody gonna forget
about trying to trade for somebody
better because of a season like that
carson wentz just got ousted in
indianapolis for 27 touchdowns and seven
picks yeah
right so
it's all about
for cleveland
especially in this particular situation
that they in they look at the rest of
the roster and they say we ready to win
and that's the that is really the
problem with baker mayfield because in
those moments
those late game moments kansas city um
he he was phenomenal against baltimore
but lamar just came back and did
something better later in the game but
it was a few games this year where you
got the ball in your hands you got an
opportunity to get in field goal range
or go make a play
couldn't do it so
i don't know if you're cleveland and
you're sitting there and you got the
possibility of getting desean watson you
should be all in
he's marcus spears espn nfl analysts so
where is the best destination for desean
watson
i think the best spot for him and it
came upon late because i was talking to
shefty is atlanta
and if i'm cleveland i'm also trying to
figure out what is matt ryan doing
like you see how to see how that that
because you look at the nfc south and i
know tom just came back
but if you look at the nfc south tom
won't be there for another two three
years
right so desean watson walks into the
nfc south
he's
he's as talented as any quarterback in
that division he can absolutely
make a franchise attractive to a lot of
guys that are looking for different
destinations he's from georgia
relationship with the blank family from
high school and them knowing him around
the area so i look at atlanta especially
a franchise right now without a number
one wide receiver arthur smith is there
who did a a great job around tannehill
in tennessee
and you think about like then you know
this as well as anybody you've been in
this game for for as long as anybody you
know when you got the guy at the signal
caller spot you gonna pull more stars
it's just it's the normal operating like
we all were waiting on aaron rodgers to
figure out what devonta adams is gonna
do and i know that situation is a little
convoluted we look at tom brady when he
came to tampa we look at matt stafford
when he went to l.a dudes want to play
with quarterbacks they win they think
they can win championships with and also
be in a city in an environment that that
is a a great place to live and all of
that so i think atlanta at first i had
carolina because he played at clemson
but between
between atlanta
and charlotte north carolina it it's the
same distance probably from from leaving
from clemson so he's familiarity with
that area and i think another thing for
this young man with all of this stuff
that he has on his plate he needs some
some some kind of sit down
around frank family people that he can
trust and have that support system
because this ain't over dude it's gonna
be a while before his off the field
issues are over and going to atlanta i
think being around his family we know
the relationship that he has with his
mom i think would be paramount for him
mentally being in that position and for
atlanta to be great because you get a
franchise quarterback yeah i talked
about math or uh matt ryan going to
indianapolis that maybe you try to take
another spin like you did with phillip
rivers
i got a veteran there i got an offensive
line to protect me i'm uh i'm a better
quarterback than the previous
quarterbacks we have and i got a good
running back here
you know i can go out and win some games
so it's a great it's a great fit yeah
it's a great fit i think frank wright
would be a static because that's frank
reich is what he want matt ryan is what
frank wright wanted carson wins to be
yeah
so
yeah i don't like when you give better
takes than me but that was a great one
help me under help me understand
randy gregory
it felt like he was going to resign with
the cowboys
and then all of a sudden he signs with
the denver broncos your reaction was
i was i was upset
from the standpoint of wanting randy
gregory because he's a hell of a
football player
but i wasn't upset because randy greger
got a five-year 70 million dollar deal
he's overcome a lot
i'm more happy about him having that
opportunity now wasn't the money the
same though the money was the same but
the terms were different and it's a way
that dallas structures their contracts
different from other places
um and i think it was some i think it
was some language and i asked shefty
this yesterday
on nfl live it was some language that
they that dallas puts in the contract
about uh suspensions and getting money
back if you
just you know
you can understand that marcus if i'm
the cowboys i got to put that language
in there 100
but i also can understand if denver does
it
that's how they got him it's basically
saying hey you might relapse you might
test you might get test hot here and
yeah and we're not going to terminate
your contract here but i normally don't
say hey an athlete needs to be loyal you
know to a team or an owner the cowboys
stood by randy gregory for many many
incidents here yeah we're about to have
our first fight yeah i'm about to have
our first
okay cause you know how you know how
this goes man
they stood by randy gregory because he's
a hell of a football player
let's not kid ourselves now this is the
same team and you know how much i love
the dallas cowboys they sign greg hardy
like so i have this conversation with
people and i understand i understand it
from like on service level like randy
gregory had these suspensions dallas
took miami
i love the cowboys all right and i i
understand how this business works from
that standpoint but if you can't play
football they ain't standing by
so that's a choice that dallas made
instead of making the choice that other
teams made and not touching randy
gregory or not wanting to sign him and i
don't know if it came back to bite him
to do it when he got 505 years 70
million dollar deal with the type of
contract that he wanted that's what
we're all trying to do regardless of if
we have
randy gregory's background right
dp if i if i got a 500 000 workout bonus
from one team and the money is the same
on another team but that 500 grand ain't
in there i'm probably leaving big dog
well usually you go to dallas if you
have problems you know that that that
that they welcome you in
they special
like wait you're going to go you go if
you can play football at a very high
level yes yeah yeah
yeah because
for the one randy gregory story i bet
it's 20 that they was like we'll see you
we'll see you never yeah
well that's the same thing with deshawn
watson if he's a defensive back a
nondescript defensive back nobody is
going to take a chance on it you know
you you got to look at the baggage and
talent and if you if talent outweighs
baggage then you get to sit in first
class if not i love this
conversation we haven't because you as
you know me i don't like fooling people
like everybody likes to have good
like good feelings about
how the nfl operates and
you know they should have we know we've
seen the nfl take some more low ground
we've seen it take some more high ground
as well but ultimately to your point dp
like you are kidding yourself if you
don't think the talent is the first
thing that these clubs think about yeah
did you ever have a crazy teammate
crazy teammate um
yeah probably tank
um tank johnson that came over from
chicago and pac-man
what well pac-man
yeah and i love them like but did they
scare you crazy huh they scarier or did
you ever i just no i never scared me i i
don't have that in my i just naturally
don't have it in my body but
what i what i will say about those two
dudes that i love number one
and they got baggage they got things
that came along with them but getting to
know them and the reason why i say
they're crazy is because
i was so impressed with how they could
play ball and have distractions going on
and still play at a very high level
i was like you crazy if you could do
that and and then two
like pac-man and i we had a bunch of
talks i loved i love to do like
literally love to do that i know he's
had his issues but if you like get
getting to the heart of the man which is
what i tried to do with most of my
teammates that i had a chance to get a
relationship with
good people that want to see other
people have success
and
really that's how i judge you i know
that you work with greeny on get up and
uh fritzy he is uh
he does this every day he likes to do
his greenie impersonation on get up you
know when greeny starts the show and
he's got all that energy
[Music]
yeah
so uh fritzy was going to do his uh mike
greenberg impersonation on uh the start
of get up and i want you to judge us all
right todd you ready let's do it okay
here we go
good morning what was baker hoping to
cook up with that statement to browns
fans and watson happens next for desean
alex the great caps off a great night
says puck the islanders don't call it a
playing game who finished first in the
first four jones in for a new team have
one cowboy got lassoed late by a herd of
broncos also don't judge his vaccination
response the yank slugger is just here
to honor a return to spring training and
i'm not joking why 60 is the new 50 in
the nba we'll explain it's time to get
up right now
damn that was good todd thanks holly
that was that was phenomenal thanks man
i damn they got ready to uh give a tape
have you ever said before on these shows
i don't have a take because if you you
have to have a take you're supposed to
have a take i have legit said i don't
have anything to say about that yeah
because there were times on the show
when somebody said well you gotta have
an opinion i said well how about i let
this breathe a little bit yeah okay
how crazy is that i'm i'm gonna pause
here for a moment you know my wife
doesn't say hey i need a hot take here
i'm gonna button up and use that with dp
i'm gonna let it breathe
uh great to talk to you again thank you
marcus always great to have you on as
always man thank you guys that's marcus
spears of the mothership contributor to
get up
and uh you can see him at 4 eastern
every week tech